to put it nicely
destiny is known for having a somewhat
confusing story
with the launch of destiny 2 both new
and returning players will most likely
be going in a little lost
but don't worry from year one through
each expansion we've covered everything
you need to know about the story
missions so far
and with plenty of destiny 2 coverage
down the road consider giving us a sub
so you don't miss a thing
everything began close to the present
day when the traveler arrived
the gigantic spherical entity was
terraforming planets throughout the
solar system though its true nature
sentient being vessel deity or something
else entirely
is unknown it possesses a mysterious
power called light
its discovery launched humanity into an
era of prosperity known as the golden
age allowing them to colonize other
planets
top scientists founded the ishtar
academy on venus and elsewhere people
developed
exos machines with human consciousness
the many technological advancements
during
this time included that of powerful ai
called war mines
one of which remained through destiny's
present day rasputin
one day a dangerous enemy of the
traveler known as the darkness
approached earth destroying nearly
everything in its path and wreaking
havoc upon what humanity had created
this is referred to as the collapse the
traveler sacrificed itself to save
humanity using its light to drive the
darkness away and create the personal ai
called ghosts that assist guardians
after the collapse the traveler remained
hovering dormant over earth and the
survivors built the last city within its
limited protection
this final populated city is where the
tower home of the guardians is located
another threat faced the city an alien
race known to humans as the fallen who
wanted the traveler for their own
[Applause]
much of year one destiny consists of set
up for things to come
roughly 700 years after the collapse you
wake in the cosmodrome you're a guardian
who's been dead for some time revived by
a ghost
the cosmodrome is an ancient spaceport
in old russia earth
now overrun by fallen like other
guardians you can wield the power of the
traveler's light and your mission is to
fight past the fallen and activate an
old
jump ship to escape to the last city
once at the tower you learn about the
vanguard who protect the city
it consists of commander zavala cade six
and okoro rey who represent each of the
three playable classes
titan hunter and warlock respectively
also at the tower is someone called the
speaker a representative of the traveler
who helps to guide guardians against the
darkness
your job as a guardian is to help
protect the last city from any threats
you must push back the darkness you
return to old russia to recover a drive
for your ship that will allow you to
travel to other planets in the solar
system
while there you encounter the hive of an
old species that worships the darkness
you fight past the fallen in the hive
and open an array that gives you access
to more technology and information
through this you discover the warmind
rasputin thought to be long dead
you protect rasputin from the fallen and
head to the moon in search of the last
guardian that had gone there
in the process the hive wake up again
you meet an exo known as the stranger
who tells you to meet her on venus if
you survive
on venus you learn about a complex
highly intelligent machine race called
the vex
the exo stranger shows up after you push
back the vex in the ishtar academy
but her story is largely nonsensical so
don't worry about it too much
i don't even have time to explain why i
don't have time to explain
from here you travel to the reef a
sovereign collection of space trash and
asteroids and meet the awoken queen of
the reef marasov
she tells you that the fallen that make
their home in the reef the only fallen
in the game who aren't your enemies
since they serve the queen
belonged to a sect called house of
wolves back on venus the fallen house of
winter has enlisted the help of a fallen
archon priest they sprung from the
queen's prison of elders
in a strike mission the guardians defeat
him and protect the knowledge kept
inside the ishtar academy
later you go to mars home of the
warmongering rhino-like race known as
the cabal
the mission is to destroy the heart of
the black garden an area on mars built
by the vex
in doing so you've taken another step to
save the traveler
the raid vault of glass involves an area
where the vex have control over time and
space
in the vaults of glass all timelines
converge inside are corpses of people
who are long dead
but because reality is bent here parts
of them and their memories still exist
the raid involves the battle and the
defeat of atheon who is said to be the
point where all of space-time converges
after you've destroyed the black
garden's heart a former guardian named
aerosmorn arrives in the tower
lurking below the surface of the moon is
crota son of oryx and hive prince who
wields the power to destroy guardian's
light
we'll come back to oryx in a bit aerys
mourn is the only survivor of a failed
assault on crotas as she asks you for
help as crota's followers are working to
bring about his return
you defeat his disciple omnigul a hive
wizard before destroying crota's essence
and stopping the attempted resurrection
in the crota's end raid the guardians
summon fight and defeat crota himself
[Music]
remember the reef in its queen the
fallen house of wolves have been serving
queen marisol for some time
but scola as a fallen captain is
attempting to unite the fragmented
fallen sects under one house
and under his command the house of
wolves betray marasov
one fallen varix of house judgment
remains loyal to the queen
your job is to hunt down scholas and
prevent the formation of a united fallen
front
you head to venus where he is studying
vex technology to find him
you capture him alive and send him to
the prison of elders then later head
there and defeat him again for some
reason
[Music]
oryx is the founder and god king of the
hive having been reborn from a pact with
the darkness
he arrives in the solar system looking
to take revenge on the guardians who are
responsible for the death of his son
crota
he rolls into the rings of saturn on his
ship the dreadnought which comes
equipped with weapons of mass
destruction
oryx's army consists of the taken which
are other enemy races that he controls
and distorts by sending them into and
back out of another dimension
they resemble shadowy versions of
existing enemies but they move as if
they're glitching in and out of reality
the reef attack oryx's army on saturn in
a suicide mission designed to help you
make it onto the dreadnought
in the process the queen and all her
forces are wiped out by the ship's super
weapon
the cabal are already there also engaged
in battle but they are in the process of
retreating from the taken
you then have to recover special tech
from k-6 in order to sneak onto the ship
where you disable its weapon and after
several more missions take down oryx
but oryx only retreats you defeat him
fully in the raid king's fall
[Music]
the fallen house of devils started
looking in old russia for something they
could use to improve themselves body and
mind
there they found siva an ancient
nanotechnology with the ability to make
them more powerful
those who use it are called splicers
lord saladin of the nearly extinct iron
lords a group formed after the collapse
with the purpose of uniting humanity
calls on you to investigate and secure
the iron temple
it's under attack by your rebuilt
septic's prime which is an enemy you
fought for the first time in a year one
strike
there you learn of the fallen splicers
and enter the vault where they are
replicating siva in order to stop the
spread
in the wrath of the machine raid you
defeat the splicers and their leaders
[Music]
that brings us to destiny 2. the sequel
begins two years after the events of the
original
the tower has been destroyed and the
last city is under attack by a cabal
faction called the red legion led by
gaul
humanity has been pushed out of their
last safe haven and your job is to
reclaim what you've lost
destiny 2 launches on ps4 and xbox one
on september 6th followed by a pc
release on october 24th
and for more destiny 2 coverage be sure
to look out for our upcoming series
destiny's children where twice a week
our uk and us offices take the reigns on
destiny 2 streams and long play features
thanks for watching
[Music]
this is great anyone want a hug no hugs